[Music]
aaron is with us in new hampshire hi
aaron how are you
[Music]
i'm doing well dave how are you better
than i deserve what's up in your world
he said dave i had a question for you um
about baby step two i'm currently in the
moment
about to move into apartment next month
so i'm currently pausing um
but i actually had a dream about asking
you this question i wanted to see what
your actual answer was
so i make forty seven and a half
thousand dollars a year
and on my car i owe 14 000 and my
student loan oh about seven and a half
now typically in the baby steps i know
that i would usually do
seven and a half first and the fourteen
but my company i work for
pays for my student loans i just have to
make an extra payment with it
um my student loan payment right now
will be about 30 bucks a month
and so part of me thinking why not just
tackle out the car
and just have the company pay the 166
and i just pay the 30 until it's paid
off
i just want to get your thoughts on that
that'd be okay yeah okay but here's the
thing
if you switch all we're doing is
switching them that's all
we're not going to slow down so you're
going to put
all the money you can find on your car
until it's gone
and then even though your company pays
the student loans you're still going to
put all the money you can find on the
student loan until it's gone
so the only advantage we're getting is
the number of months it takes you to pay
off your car
you're going to get some money out of
your company but that's all
so how fast you're going to pay off your
car um
my car will be paid off probably in the
next
couple months i have about ten thousand
the bank i'll probably have around
by the time i get there it'll probably
be around like thirteen and a half
to like thirteen thousand i'm sorry wait
a minute i'm sorry let's let's start
again because
you you said you were doing the baby
steps and i got confused
okay so um the baby steps are baby step
one's a thousand dollars
any other money you have goes on your
smallest debt
and you work your debts off smallest to
largest in baby step
two and so your car balance is what
again
it is 14 000. okay so what we're gonna
do is we're gonna have a four thousand
dollar car balance when you get off the
phone
or actually a five because you need to
keep one thousand in your account
you said you had 10 in the bank right i
do yeah sorry i
i didn't clarify this piece my bad um
because i'm moving into an apartment and
i i have an idea what the expenses look
like but i'm currently
pausing on baby steps oh you did say you
did say that that's why the money is
there because you're paused
correct okay okay then i won't be such a
smart ankle
okay don't worry sorry about that
all right so um uh so all right
so okay yeah let's do that now when you
finish
your move any money that's left above a
thousand goes on whichever debt is
remaining agreed
agreed because you push play again yes
okay now once we're doing that then when
the car is paid off
then you attack the student loan with
the same
vengeance that you would have even if
your company wasn't paying it i don't
want to use your company money as an
excuse to stay in debt longer
instead we're going to use your company
money as a way to get out faster
but that only works if you put the same
amount on the debts you would have and
you should be debt-free in one year
i agree okay um so really at the end of
the day what we're actually going to end
up getting out of this company
is about 1500 bucks
that's yeah that's about right um a
quick another quick question on baby
step two that i
wasn't sure about is when i pay off when
i'm paying off the debt
is it okay just to pile up the cash and
then pay it off in one check
or does it make sense to just keep
throwing extra payments and then
it's better off to pay the extra
payments because both of these are on
what's called
simple interest and whatever your
interest rate
is on your debts is larger than the
interest rate you would get in savings
and you're getting credit for the day
you send it once a month you can't get a
daily credit but once a month is
compounded
i see so it works out better you're
doing really good here's what the good
news about your situation is aaron
you're really really thinking about this
you're really analyzing it
and you're paying attention the reason
most people are broke is
they don't pay attention they don't have
any idea
what's going on and you've got what's
known as a clue
so you're looking for all these nuanced
little answers down inside the program
and that means that you
really are dialed in and that's a cool
thing i'm so proud of you you're gonna
do great